Your brain is bathing in about half a cup
of fluid, with up to 24mL being made an hour…
but your skull is pretty firm and doesn’t
expand… soooo where does all this fluid
go??
Much like how buildings drain excess fluids
through pipes that lead into a sewage system,
our bodies also have a network of vessels
for moving things, like fluids, around.
It’s called the lymphatic system, and while
this network seems to run all throughout the
body, it hadn’t been observed around much
of the brain in humans… until recently.
Using magnetic resonance imaging, or MRI,
clinicians injected a dye-like substance to
help them visualize the pooling of liquid
in human and marmoset brains.
In MRIs of both species, they saw evidence
that fluid leaked out of the blood vessels
surrounding the brain…..
And collected into what seemed like lymphatic
vessels!
This is a big deal, because we didn’t know
where these lymphatic vessels were or if they
were even THERE.
Now we know they’re part of the outermost
layer of connective tissue surrounding the
brain-- called the dura.
This finding will open up so many more avenues
of research….
Imagine that you didn’t know where any of
the pipes were in your home, or that you couldn’t
even find the toilet, really…If something
were ever going wrong, you wouldn’t be able
to find the source of the problem and Sparing
you the detailed description - it’d be a
stinkin’ mess.
And we’ve gone years without being able
to fully identify this path of waste out of
the brain, and this might be relevant to degenerative
diseases related to aging.
Like Alzheimer’s disease, where toxic by-products
build up in the brain instead of getting removed.
But that’s just one avenue -- the lymphatic
system does so much more than remove waste.
In other parts of the human body and in rodent
brains, the lymphatic system helps traffic
immune cells between the blood and different
tissues.
Interestingly, while the blood vessels directly
supplying blood to the brain have a protective
layer called the blood brain barrier controlling
what gets in -- the arteries and lymphatic
vessels OUTSIDE the brain don’t have the
same gating system.
This means that they are an easier entry point
for dysfunctional immune cells to get on the
highway to the brain.
This has been observed in other parts of the
human body, and also in rodent brains, but
this study didn’t get that far.
Instead, it showed the lymphatic vessels were
PRESENT in the dura, that fluid COLLECTED
in them, and that it drained out of the brain.
BUT, future studies will focus on whether
immune cells can also travel into the brain
via these vessels.
Because if they can, the researchers hypothesize
these newly located lymphatic vessels might
be incorrectly trafficking immune cells around
the brain in diseases like multiple sclerosis.
There are still lots of mind-blowing questions
to ask about the lymphatic system surrounding
the brain, but hey, at least we know how our
heads won’t literally explode from all the
fluid in em!
Thanks for watching, Julian has a great video
about the Blood Brain Barrier and how it works
And it’s awesome. You can watch it here.
Oh and one last thing: Previous
studies in mice found that there’s an increase
in fluid flow during sleep -- so perhaps these
lymphatic vessels are working extra duty to
pump out toxins while we slumber and maybe
that’s why sleep is so important?